[Applause]
this is the moment you've waited for
I'll start this review by saying that I
absolutely hate musicals bar eight-mile
which is sort of a musical I suppose I
find them corny row and seriously
lacking in character development
naturally when my girlfriend informed me
that she wanted to go see the greatest
showman I dragged my heels but weeks and
weeks that came up with all manner of
excuses as to why I couldn't go see the
film whether it was it's mixed reviews
January release or price I put forward a
reason as to why we couldn't go
eventually I gave in because I felt
guilty that had forced her to see over
12 superhero films in the last year
women's rights in all that and Hugh
Jackman has in my eyes never really put
in a less than stellar performance as
the film star had in chance broke out I
thought oh he will go again however
within the first 10 minutes the movie
completely swept me off my feet sure
there was the usual over-the-top dancing
and singing through the dialogue that I
did tested in the genre but beneath the
surface there was something childlike a
promise of a better tomorrow for all no
matter color or creed throughout the
movie I became enamored with its songs
being brought to almost the brink of
tears by the absolutely outstanding
never enough
at the film's midsection handling a
wealth of subjects such as race the
class divided and deformity the movie
has a lot on its plate to its credit
though it never feels out of its depth
and every theme is handled with a wealth
of sincerity as always Hugh Jackman put
his all into the film and it's not hard
to be taken by his charisma and talent
the man simply loves what he's doing and
he's very very good at it he's aided by
phenomenal supporting casts in every
character has their arc that strengthens
them throughout I've seen many
criticisms that the portrayal of PT
Barnum is a little whitewashed missing
most of his manner at Disney face him
and paint him as a lovable rogue
while some dislike this I actually think
that it ties in beautifully with the
movie's overarching motif the circus may
have had its dark aside but when the
lights were on that was all put to the
side in favor of selling us a dream that
is what the greatest showman does it
presents an ideal and shiz away from the
dark history that envelops Barnum
it's the perfect summation of its
majestic appeal and AIDS the movie
metaphorically in several ways if like
me you dislike musicals and try and put
your prejudices to one side and enjoy
this film for it is pure escapism much
like the real Barnum you will leave your
troubles at the door and forget about
life for a while magic from start to
finish I give the greatest showman a
nine out of ten so what did you think of
the film I know this is sort of a bit
different from the John Rowe that I
normally cover but it'd be great to hear
your feedback on whether this movie won
you round two do you like musicals now
are you going to see
chitty-chitty-bang-bang at the theater
down the road comment below let me know
and subscribe and like this video please
please thanks very much for checking
this out and you can see more of my
movie game comic and TV reviews at
definition code at UK Cheers